the last lesson introduced you to
clauses and gave you a brief definition
of a sentence this time we move on to
phrases phrases are basic units and
sentence structure they allow us to
group words together into broader units
where each group of words acts as its
own unit every phrase as a head word
which is the main content word or the
main function word in that phrase so a
noun phrase is based around a noun and
the noun is the head a verb phrase is
based around a head verb and a
prepositional phrase around a
preposition phrases have three parts the
first part is the head the main word
mentioned above the second part is the
compliment which may be optional and
usually occurs next to the head it's
adjacent to the head the third part is
the specifier which qualifies the head
in some way let me give you an example
in the red car the word car is clearly
the noun in the noun phrase so it's the
head word of that noun phrase red which
occurs right next to the noun modifies
the noun it's an adjective and the word
V specifies the noun
a key feature of phrases is that they
can embed into other phrases you'll
notice that phrases will build up into
other phrases which will then build up
into larger and larger phrases until we
get to a sentence which is itself an
entire phrase so all of these are
grammatically connected units here's an
English example of a phrase embedded
into another phrase prepositional
phrases have a head word a preposition
like to 4-under before prepositions are
used with nouns and the nouns going to
be part of a noun phrase in the
prepositional phrase to the store I have
a preposition to and I have a noun
phrase of this store I don't look at
them side by side as parallel words
instead I see that the noun phrase the
store embeds into the prepositional
phrase to this store and this is a key
feature for building sentences with
phrases when we use phrases to look at
the structure of grammar this is how
languages build sentences how do we
display this in
bedding hierarchical structure visually
well one way to do it is with brackets
this is straightforward enough with
simple examples like the prepositional
phrase to the store we'll put each
phrase into a set of brackets so we can
enclose the entire noun phrase the store
in brackets after that we put the entire
prepositional phrase to the store in its
own set of brackets and that allows us
to write out the structure of phrases so
that we can analyze them and discuss
this embedding syntax behind them
we focused entirely on phrases but
there's a competing model of basic
sentence structure instead of looking
for unit chunks of language phrases we
can consider how words depend on each
other instead a simple phrase analysis
of my boss AIDS soup begins by breaking
the sentence into a subject noun phrase
my boss and a predicate verb phrase ate
soup where the predicate breaks down
further into head verb and the verbs
object in a dependency analysis on the
other hand the verb has a subject and an
object that depend on it no main verb no
subject of a main verb and no object
either this keeps the discussion at the
level of the words and the relationship
to one another rather than abstracting
up to larger and larger phrase units
crucially though it does not break
sentences into subject the doer of the
action versus predicate the action and
everything acted upon take the other
example to the store the preposition 2
has a dependency that goes this way and
the article depends on the noun governed
by that preposition phrases or
dependencies are 2 ways of breaking
syntax down into the smallest
relationship between words once you
understand them it's time to move on to
the next lesson
you